beaucoup
ils ont tous alors
c'est tout
treize émerger tic
donc bière frédéric murienne jours c'est
bon on y va
je connais le froid cette nuit parce que
j'ai eu quelques expériences ou ou la
nuit j'ai eu très froid sous la tente et
en fin de compte je suis couvert à même
de troubles
donc la très bonne tenue
plane si les y voilà
voilà
je crois que c'est surtout le portage
qui fait que je suis un petit peu à la
traîne
et puis bon aussi certainement le manque
d'endurance ça c'est sûr
mais calais enfin non non on n'est pas
l'autre sous les 2
m
donc voyez les bons peuples est sûre ce
sera la pelle la crête vosgienne voilà
taniguchi alors ça va être avec une
berceuse super g cet avis et le gâteau
bon allez un petit point cartes avant le
départ mais voir par là alors on avait
déjà un peu regardé la carte donc qui
rappelle nous sommes à mme facebook
grosses gouttes première première étape
pour ce matin moutier des faits qui sort
de nous faire le petit guide le guide
pour aller aux mutilés fille j'ai aboli
merci qui est intéressant c'est que ben
on va se tromper ou on va tomber sur des
choses qui bien sûr ne correspondront
pas la carte
ça nous permettra au cours de balades
éventuellement dire bah tiens on devait
pas être là bas n'ont plus rien ne pas
être du tout la vague est encore une ou
deux baguettes
je pense que j'ai plus de soucis avec
les 9 kg qui a accumulé ces derniers
mois faute de l'opération que par
rapport à mon genou
mon genou je veux essayer de l'oublier
au maximum et puis nous pas m'en soucier
quoi bon c'est sûr ça me pose un peu des
petits problèmes de temps à autre plus
d'appréhension que de vraiment de
doullens fin je me sens un petit peu
mais plus d'appréhension que de douleur
mais vous pouvez vous avez été 2 heures
avant de continuer un petit point avec
muriel vrai qu'elle me montrent
précisément sur la carte où on est c'est
possible et pourquoi c'est possible et
comment c'est possible je connais vous
seul comme ça c'est la base en orient et
n'offrent alors voilà on fait bouger la
carte pour que le nord correspond pas
mal qu'est ce qui va nous dire où on est
sur ce chemin là mais on est sûrs alors
là ça descend là ça redescend donc voilà
avec la course ça ça peut pas bouger se
dire qu'à un moment un moment le voile
léger à mais le chemin qui monte qui
monte on voit ils coupent des courbes
brune dans un sens donc ça veut dire
qu'ils montent et à un moment donné
or il en suit une et on voit qu'ils leur
coupe une dans la descente d'un désordre
donc précisément on sait qu'on est sur
cette zone là où il est vraiment
parallèle la courbe de niveau
donc là on roule et faut pas rater fond
de valence et en scène un petit
accessoire
j'ai fait des études de géographie
donc voilà je suis géographe mais j'ai
jamais exercé de profession dans ce
domaine là ces études là sont assez loin
pour moi donc ça me fait un petit ça me
rafraîchit un petit peu les idées à ce
niveau là maintenant de la partager ça
avec d'autres personnes ça va peut-être
pas être gagnée d'afrique vraiment
révisé pour ça je pense
mais chacun se cherche chez ford comme
un petit coin favori
s'il y en a qui arrivent à trouver des
graines de carvi donc on a vu la plante
hier mais je bats il y en a du jaune
donc mais je crois que les graines sont
déjà bientôt b le sucre et non non non
on regarde donc là la graine du quart
vit pour ce faire on n'avait pas vu
alors on est vraiment en fin de récolte
là j'ai encore donc la fleur avec l'ont
bel la plupart des graines sont tombés
donc là si vous voulez vous pouvez vous
vous gaver de graines fait passer sans
secouer trop parce que toutes les
graines vont tomber très bon sa peinture
sans vraiment eu trouble le goût de
carvi le goût du cumin c'est plutôt
agréable ce qu'on est en train de
découvrir le haut niveau passe et des
épices ou des empreintes des condiments
mais c'est très très désagréable de de
découvrir tout ça pas manger trop rude
et myrtille là je ne découvre pas ça
c'est plutôt la gourmandise
attention dire importer je me sens très
bien parce que mon sac était un peu trop
plein dans ce faux pas mais des choses
dedans
dans ce que je vais faire demain je
prendrai le sac de quelques années là où
on met la nourriture pour l'emporter et
servir thierry sac voilà jérôme s'est
proposé à échanger le sac avec moi voilà
pour demain
comme il a pris le café hier qu'ils
étaient lourds
du cochon dans les vosges tous les jours
si je vous dis que ce sur quoi vous êtes
à 6 à 3 158 places et tout de suite ça
diffère sanitaires c'est lié avec la
bretagne
excellent i avec solène ya la bretelle
le massif armoricain et le massif
vosgien
eh bien figurez-vous que c'était le même
ne former qu'un est voilà donc les
vosgiens et les bretons même combat
lequel est parti mais n'en est pas parce
qu on s'est érodée est en fait le massif
vosgien aimé remonter quand les apps se
sont fait donc la ceiba enfin quand on a
un peu le panorama sur le sur d'autres
semaine de rando à partir par la balle a
alors je vous dis pas sur quel boss sont
pas ça mais grosso modo passe en face et
on finira la semaine non comme le
passage sur la crête sans arbres
kastelberg honey koala samedi
normalement si tout se passe bien on est
encore les neuf là ou quoi
avec vos amis
on va les faire le chamois sur les
rochers on va les faire chez moi sur les
rochers alors pourquoi tous ces spots
non voilà pour le pour le propriétaire
la carrière c'est du déchet d'accord
donc il est venu arracher le rocher on
va les voir au dessus quand il est venu
arracher deux rochers à montagne ça
c'est du déchet alors pour quelle raison
exactement je n'en sais rien ce moment
parce que les fibres croisés que ça se
passait pas bien
historiquement c'est une activité
complètement artisanale ça n'a rien à
voir avec ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est des agriculteurs qui avaient des
droits sur des ce qu'on appelle des
boules de granit des voix des gros blocs
apparent et il venait taille et le pavé
tout simplement au début des petites
formes des bassins des choses comme ça
et très rapidement c'est l'industrie du
pavé qui s'est mis en place
le granit c'est vraiment une roche qui
vient du fond de la croûte terrestre et
qui monte qui se refroidit
progressivement donc christianisme c'est
pour ça aussi qu'elle ça me donne des
caractéristiques de couleur ou de fans
de forme être touchés qu'ils sont très
sympathiques le faire il va tâter le
granit en rose le cuivre veulent tâter
anvers donc voilà en fonctions s'il ya
d'autres minéraux qui se rajoute on va
obtenir des teintes différentes dans le
secteur ici on a ce qu'on appelle le
gris bleu essentiellement vous allez
voir on va traverser l'on va passer sur
les gros blocs passera un peu où vous
voudrez mais là il ya vraiment des blocs
où on voit des superbike cristallisation
de sur le granit coiffe donc je vous
laisse divaguer son petit cheval
les frappadingues lave les voir donc le
granit et une base au co on révise c'est
quoi la base du granit à part ça quoi
le quartz et le coince elle se bat elle
tout cas je n'y ai pas noir n'est pas le
mec là est quelquefois dedans bien sûr
il se forme d'autres choses mais pas la
regarder ce que là on voit bien la
différence entre le comment le granit on
va dire classique quoi les cristaux
qu'on les cristaux qu'on voit d'habitude
le quartz feldspath elle mika et puis
cette phase là où d'autres d'autres
cristallisation super brillantes sont
venus rejoindre nos trois minéraux de
faim de base quoi c'était tellement ça
parce que ça pourquoi autour du cou
c'est alors c'est une cristallisation
différentes je t'aurais mais je suis pas
spécialiste
je veux dire une connerie tête du
manganèse ou
les secteurs vous pensez double de woods
il faut revenir ici et là
à quand même je suis là
voilà
entrez entrez entrez votre maison ce
soir sûr que je vous propose moi de
vivre soir c'est confort et sécurité
c'est à dire on va partir de finalement
pas grand chose comme vous le voyez il
ya des bâches celles qu'on trouve dans
les camions en outillage finalement si
on réussit à bien vivre ce sera pas à
cause des gadgets que je vous emmener
ici mais il sera bien parce qu'on sera
bien entendu ensemble et alors
l'objectif de la douleur qui va passer
c'est de transformer cet endroit qui est
pour l'instant qui est bas nous on se
sent pas chez nous d'ici et d'ailleurs à
ce qu'on sent bien ça sent bon et on
commence à se rendre compte que
finalement on peut passer une soirée et
une nuit agréable ici
face à envoyer sur les panneaux chalet
ducharme est en fait c'est pas du tout
cette odeur de rabbi web
c'est une première pour moi on va de
surprise en surprise donc c'est cool on
va pouvoir être autonome la nuit pouvoir
passer une bonne nuit en communauté
partageant n'avoir pas mon avis et puis
on verra si elle plonge de la pub pour
dormir comme quoi être fou parce que
sinon elle perd si la lettre la nuit
d'enfer
parce que sinon il ya des tentes un
rapide que voilà quoi
alors vous 17 mai l'iran
parienti mijoter dinde aux légumes de
saison
j'aime ce côté du bivouac sauvage va se
connaît tous ensemble c'est un petit peu
comme un espèce de nid au milieu de la
forêt ça ça me plaît bien
c'est simple aussi ça n'ont pas beaucoup
d'investissement donc on peut le
reproduire facilement quelque part le
confort qu'on a ce soir si on a du
confort c'est nous qui l'avons qui
l'avons fait de nos mains c'est nous qui
l'avons qui en sommes les artisans
bon bah c'est parti pour le munster vous
allez sans attendre votre assiette sur
une tranche de pain
et puis je sers levens terre cuite
attendait pour des chapelles des balles
qui peut poser sur l'assiette c'est vrai
quoi on peut être à 900 mètres
d'altitude dans les vosges paoute avoir
chaud et manger à repas royal
et encore je vous pose pas de la nuit
qui va suivre
on va être comme des coqs en pâte
afférents ils s'inquiètent toujours où
ils avaient peur d'avoir froid là il a
trop chaud donc déjà hier nous a fait le
coup
c'est un petit instrument qui permet
d'imiter quelques bruits d'animaux qui
permet aussi de se repérer dans la forêt
et puis qui permet de bien rire c'est
donc une file aplatir ici j'ai coupé si
en pointe avec les saisons j'ai posé mes
lèvres ici et je suis soufflé fort
dedans et je vais volume et comme un
joueur d'harmonica
janota sauvage
donc je me transforme en a eu femelles
ne sais pas ce que l'on appelle voilà
le fait qu'ils puissent dormir sans
quasiment rien plats mis au point qu'à
la forêt y voir ce qu'ils vont pouvoir
prendre conscience que dans la nature ce
quelque chose dangereuse accueillant à
partir du moment où on laisse tomber et
quelques barrières culturelles on va
dire mai prochain duel plutôt pour
l'alignement leur 100 mètres maximum
hugo lapierre
alors j'ai même pas eu froid j'étais
super revanche dans l'école entramis
d'un tipi lui mais bon un peu d'air
c'est super d'ici là vous viendrez voir
je vous montre un petit peu pour la
salle de bar ceux que ça intéresse on se
prend c'est sa bonne quinzaine de louche
comme laisser de l'eau dans le cumulus
pour les suivants voilà une fois que
vous avez votre stock la salle de bain
c'est vous choisissez votre salle de bar
d'aller où bon vous semble
il sera très très bien je vais faire ma
toilette près du prêt du joli sapin qui
est la poignée
ici le ciel est quand même quasiment
tout bleu et je pense que derrière la
lisière de forêt c'est autre chose parce
que on vient d'entendre vraiment de gros
coup de tonnerre nos pasteurs si des
gros coup de tonnerre la prévision d'
arriver de bonne heure pour se protéger
de l'orage se confirme quoi on va
essayer de faire ville avec ce matin et
voilà parce que ça se trouve on aura
quand même des zones où on va avoir du
mal de passer si l'orage est trop trop
rude quoi
les aléas météo sont là plus tôt que
prévu donc on va s'organiser
bon c'est bien on est à l'abri sous
bivouac on va pouvoir s'habiller au sec
puis après on va voir
c'est vraiment l'orage reste sous forme
de pluie ou si ça se transforme avec de
la grêle
exactement nous rappellerons clader
poche qui forme d'éclair on foule s'est
écoulé
on a un carrefour on va attendre un
petit peu spéciale de la carte gérard
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya beaucoup
aimeraient bien qu'ils nous note sur la
carte pour voir si si je suis un peu ce
monsieur parce que hier il avait
tendance un peu assez moqué muriel avec
la carte
donc on va voir si les plus malins
aujourd'hui s'il est capable de mettre
le doigt sur la carte pour me dire on
est là aussi à 909 exactement bravo d'or
noir faire pour être sûr qu'on est bon
je crois qu'il peut nous dire à droite
sur une clairière a vu la belle carrière
à droite
voilà c'est ce qu'on vous a toujours dit
c'est que la perte elle peut être fausse
là nous avons une belle carrière quelle
belle forestière voilà la justice art
ici depuis longtemps on peut on peut on
peut essayer de gagner un quart d'heure
sur le parcours pour rejoindre le
prochain la prochaine étape soit on suit
la route
enfin le chemin soit on comprend à
gauche que non et là t'es pas d'accord
et un choeur joue ce soir c'est n'y a
plus du tout d'accord non mais je vais
dire on va peut-être n'en voit pas de
problème
particularité du frêne les petits
bourgeons tout noir bonjour qui sont
déjà là 1 on pas tout de suite
voilà qu'on en profite puisque on a
encore des beaux fresnes dans le coin
ils sont pas tous malades mais ça
commence à on a déjà coupé dans les
vosges était aussi atteint de cette
maladie donc pour l'instant il ya un
observatoire national il repère les
endroits et puis l'idée bien sûr cette
trouver des commandes des cultivars qui
sont pas à tapha qui sont pas atteints
par ce champignon ça se manifeste comme
en fait ce champignon se sèche et
cherchent ils perdent leurs feuilles
sèches
ils sont beaux à couper tout regarder
à la perspective d'un scooter
bon
à mesure qu'on va réussir